The star has entered here
Chasing the 4th generation, ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh  Speaking of which, some people
say it's just an illusion, but look, the reason I told you to go home the other day was actually because I was seeing an illusion.
But when I was told to do something like this, I left the flowers in the
follow-up, so if I don't go back quickly, I'll be entangled in that right away, so I'll attack
even the flowers.
Come looking for Ishida, I
'm scared, absolutely no,
Mr. Smith and the others.
Isn't that doll's love stone?
What the
heck, even
though you're scared, I left it there, but
you can do it Never bar until when are you a cup girl?
I have something I want to do Can
I have some time?
[Music]